but it's not that it's not that bad
now they're also saying
that temperatures are going to be so hot
that maybe it's easier to just die
it's going to be over 100 degrees
everywhere
well you have to like get like in the
south and stuff well it's gonna be hot
it's gonna be hot in the old antebellum
south and they're they're they're saying
that might be easier for people instead
of going out to a beach or local pool to
just die in their house
it might be easier for them and we're
always trying to
i think it's really about what's easy
for people and it just may be easier
to just die in the sweltering heat it's
the type of heat where if the air
conditioning goes it's over right if
like that texas energy grid crashes
it's over grandma's done
it's so hot
there was a guy in death valley the
other day in california he's which by
the way don't drive through that you
idiot
his car breaks down guess what happens
to him dead
probably didn't make it long yeah yeah i
mean it's rough out there yeah so now
how hot is it gonna be what are we
talking so right here we got uh
so for the next seven days highs will be
15 to 25 degrees above normal and
california will see triple digits on
thermometers from fresno and all over
the place so you're looking at uh
it says 65 million americans will expect
highs above 100 degrees this week so
pretty much uh half the country for the
most part it's the summer
get into it
you know
get into it like i i i don't i don't
love the whining
get into the summer you have an
opportunity right now
to [ __ ]
enjoy the weather there's so much things
that are available now that you couldn't
you couldn't do them
in a colder climate
there's a lot of things that you can do
as an american right now
that you couldn't do in a colder climate
for example
after eating at famous dave's barbecue
have a coronary or what you think is a
coronary event in your car
but ends up just being indigestion
and you were sweating it's brought on by
the heat
and you might have a nice lunch at
famous daves get into your car
while you're adjusting yourself in your
seat you shake something loose
you start feeling a pulsating throbbing
pain in your chest
and you think to yourself [ __ ] i'm done
but it's actually indigestion and you
start pouring sweat because of the heat
these are the summer experiences that
americans are gonna have
there'll be fireworks for the fourth of
july there'll be kids
running around without shoes on bikes
trying to potentially rob you
it's the summer
this is a fun
part of the you know year where people
are just hot angry
the cost of everything is up there's
going to be fights in the street
you're going to see people get real
drunk you know what's fun in the summer
those street festivals where everyone
lives in a [ __ ] and they go let's
close each side of the [ __ ] all off
and get drunk right here
let's sit out
let's walk out on our [ __ ] street that
we live because we don't have any money
to go anywhere else
and let's pretend and let's have all the
kids out and they're all fighting with
pool noodles and in a few years it'll be
guns
and just get them everybody boozed up
and put the [ __ ] beards in the
koozies and get [ __ ] up on your street
which sucks and you and it [ __ ] up
traffic so all the drug dealers got to
circle back and go around and it's it's
annoying but that's what's fun you have
little festivals in the summer
you have little
things where you let you go let's be
festive we all hate each other and we
all don't have any money
but what we have right now is we can
they will legally allow us to block off
each side of our street so that we can
get drunk in the middle of our street
and we can set up a few tables with hot
dogs
and that will be our summer
festival
it's like have you ever been to one of
these i've been more than i want to
admit yeah and sometimes there's a
parade too right sometimes there's a
parade
local marching band yeah bring out the
local marching band and the lions club
there's like an old people walking
there's their walking
it's independence day it's the ancient
order of hibernians it's the [ __ ]
knights of malta whatever it is it's you
got every old group there's five
veterans they all [ __ ]
lit babies on fire in vietnam and
they're marching and everyone's like
thank you for your service they all did
the my life massacre and they're all
walking around and then we just cordon
off our street so that everybody can eat
grizzle burgers and drink booze and
listen to the sound of gunshots it's the
summer
in america it's a beautiful place and a
beautiful time you should enjoy it if
you're rich you get to do many other
things but if you are not this is what
your summer looks like in america
it looks like a street festival
where
your white child is dressed like a gang
banger
and you are telling the neighbor that
he's doing quote much better
that is summer
in america
if you don't have a lot of money you
will not be
in the south of france
you will not be on nantucket
maybe you are
at a nice little street festival in a
suburb of tampa
talking about your daughter who has
three children now
she's 24 years old and she's just had
her third
child and you're telling the neighbors
how cute they are but they can hear
there's a hint of worry in your voice
summer in the usa
that's what it is and there's nothing
wrong with it there's nothing wrong and
your big fat daughter waddles out with
her three mistakes and she's got a
tattoo on her big rib eye sigh steak
size foot and she comes out and she
cracks open a beer and she goes is there
a burger
she has a long island accent because you
guys move there
and you go oh i thought moving her down
to tampa would calm her the [ __ ] down
but she spit out three kids you know
she's a cashier at a gas station there's
nothing wrong with that
absolutely nothing wrong but she's
stealing
and there's something wrong with that
because you know that that job's not
gonna last forever
but she's getting along with her brother
better now probably because you're both
cooking meth together in the backyard
have some potato salad we got it at the
store it's summer in america you're to
enjoy it there's no school
so that means the kids have to shoot
each other somewhere else and it won't
make the news
isn't that nice
it's summer in america
let your children run around they're
being chased through the town by
pedophiles summer in america put them in
a recreation program where some weird 45
year old single freak wants to watch
them run around and you're very nervous
some summer in america enjoy it it's fun
there's nothing wrong with it
send the kids to camp
they can come back trans nothing wrong
with that depends on which camp they go
to
send them to uh you know in the woods
camp they come back talking about the
shapes of skulls and jews
send them to a theater arts camp they
come back with blue hair telling you you
don't even own the house you live in
you're colonizing pig
you gotta chew but get them away from
you you deserve it it's summer and
summer